so hi everybody today I'd like to
present to you my PhD thesis work on
taking inspiration from expert creative
practice to design crowd sourcing
techniques for supporting creativity ooh
platforms like Amazon Mechanical Turk
and others have made it possible for
hundreds of people to come together to
produce creative work at massive scale
projects like the Johnny Cash project
asked workers to draw individual frames
which were combined to create a
reinterpretation of a music video while
other past work has looked at how to
achieve more complex projects by
building workflows that allow crowd
workers to build on each other's work
oops so doing this makes a whole lot of
sense because it's this breaking down of
work into independent parts that allows
crowdsourcing to be so good at achieving
large complex task quickly and at scale
and currently crowds use a number of
proven strategies to split up this work
so in many crowdsourcing systems
individual workers are encouraged to
submit independent submissions that may
net them a monetary bonus or benefit of
some kind of its ultimately selected
other systems divide the work into
smaller chunks assigning them to workers
with the intent of merging work together
at the end so the Johnny Cash project is
an example of this as our projects like
Galaxy Zoo folded and other tasks where
a large amount of repetitive work like
data collection or labeling needs to be
done and more recently systems have
explored more complex workflows styles
that resemble an assembly line soylent
for example propose the work flow
pattern pattern called find fix verify
indicating three different tasks that
could be done by different workers in
that order two together perform the task
of copy editing text research has even
looked at how to get the crowd to create
their own workflows based on given goals
so all of these strategies requires pre
determining a particular desired outcome
and prescribing to crowds exactly how to
create that outcome this usually means
that using these strategies crowd
workers work very independently any
connection between workers is usually in
the form of work being passed from one
work or to another and this limits the
kind of work that we can crowdsource so
to compare how do experts manage
themselves when they creates
of the creative processes that expert
creators already use may be an untapped
source of reliable creative strategies
that may help us understand how the
crowd can influence the direction of
complex creative projects so we know for
example about experts continually create
and revise constraints to develop
purpose for their work they reflect
during practice and they make use of
existing patterns for solutions rather
than reinventing the wheel so in other
words no expert creator simply competes
and votes with themselves they may
create alternative solutions to a
problem but rather than taking a
solution wholesale as you might see in a
crowdsourcing system experts often
combine or modify solutions by taking
the bigger picture into account and can
even make the judgment call to start
over and try a new approach so what if
we could get the crowd to also
thoughtfully revise their work as they
work if we can do that we might be able
to expand the ability of crowd sourcing
to tackle even more complex
collaborative projects my research
focuses on adapting expert creative
practice into social computing and
crowdsourcing environments in order to
make these strategies accessible to a
crowd of non-experts that is rather than
breaking down work by splitting it in
two independent steps maybe we should
enable the crowd to follow a process
that looks more like an expert instead
of doing creative crowdsourcing like
crowdsourcing maybe we can do creative
crowdsourcing like creativity so in this
talk I'll talk about three expert
practices that I've been exploring
through several projects first I'll talk
about ensemble where I explored how
leader created constraints can help a
crowd coordinate in writing short
fiction stories then i'll talk about
mechanical novel where i looked at how
to get the crowd to engage in reflection
and revision on their own we're over 200
unique workers were able to work
together to write short fiction without
a leader and lastly I'll talk about
mosaic where I looked at how to design
online creative communities so that they
focus not just on showing off final
successes but on helping creators
support each other while they work and
show how you are able to build up a
community of creators that shared their
creative processes with each other so
first ensemble
this project we looked at the expert
practice of creating and revising
constraints so in ensembl we structured
crowd work around these constraints
rather than a specific overall goal so
most of us are familiar with examples of
how the crowd can produce incredible
pieces of collaborative work but though
the web has been able to create the
great collaborative encyclopedia it
hasn't been able to create the great
collaborative novel and you would think
that we would be able to take a leaf
from the book of one of the most
successful crowd powered systems on the
web like Wikipedia and apply it to
creative collaboration online but a
completely open collaborative system can
make it hard for group to the site on
and adhere to a single creative vision
on the other hand in highly structured
approaches participants might build up a
story piece by piece by adding a few
sentences at a time but without the
ability to coordinate at a higher level
collaborators end up with incoherent
patchwork stories that turn out more
like wild improv games than a novel so
what can we do about this from past
research on how creativity works we know
that one thing that we can do is make
use of constraints to limit and direct
the search through a creative space for
a story so with constraints a creative
work can be made more manageable by
reducing the space of possible choices
and this also make sure that all the
people working on the story are
brainstorming in the same areas of that
space so in addition rather than
following some kind of a linear process
we also know that expert writers
structure their writing around goals
that they create and revised as they
work so what if we adopted these
perspectives on using goals and creative
constraints by putting leaders in charge
of creating goals to direct work on the
story and putting collaborators
potentially the crowd in charge of
fleshing out the story with those goals
in mind so based on this we decided to
explore potential online collaborative
storytelling strategies by building a
tool ensemble based on the hypothesis
that the crowd and the individual have
complementary creative strengths so so
to the Sun we built the platform where
individual leaders start a story by
creating initial structures for stories
using mini writing prompts which is the
where the idea of constraints comes in
collaborators can then focus on the type
of work that they're good at around
these constraints brainstorming
proposing possible segments of writing
or discussing potential solutions the
leader can then do things like choose a
winning contribution or merge or edit
existing contributions to better fit the
overall vision for the story so using
this platform the main question that we
wanted to ask was whether or not this
division of creative responsibility
would produce successful collaborations
so in particular could the crowd support
the writing process for this lead author
and to look at this question we ran a
month long story writing competition we
ran in collaboration with the creative
writing Department here we're over 100
volunteer users from the web start on
almost 50 stories together or over 50
stories together out of these 20 were
completed and submitted its entries into
the competition and so for this study
team sizes were fairly small with a
median of two people working on each
story we provided a prompt asking teams
to write a story about what happens to
stolen bikes and we got a number of
interesting stories including a
character study of a man who obsessively
steals bikes due due to childhood trauma
and a story where bikes try to escape
their bonds and oppressors and journey
to bike heaven and this was one example
of the prompts that leaders created with
this particular scene asking for details
filling out the introduction to the
story so as you can see contributors are
conversing with the leader about these
high-level story details but in general
people would also use these comment
spaces to point out low-level issues
like grammar and spelling errors or
point out if they've made any changes to
the story so
to summarize our findings here we found
that on the leader side of things we
just tended to maintain creative
Authority with half of their activity
being spent revising paragraphs written
themselves so in practice this meant
that leaders were manually integrating
ideas provided by others and submitted
paragraphs or comments into the story
rather than taking contributions as is
so in other words leaders were
interpreting contributions for the high
level idea being suggested and using
them as examples or points of comparison
while manually tweaking existing work
contributors on the other hand were
limited to writing comments or
paragraphs in response to any prompts
that were provided by the leader so when
they submitted when they cemented
paragraphs for a story they were able to
do so without overwriting other people's
proposals for that section and because
of this contributors could use this as a
safe way to show rather than describe
their ideas for the story so one
participant put it it was harder for
them to describe what they wanted to do
rather than to just do it so in this way
and someone unexpectedly this feature
that we had built to that was meant to
facilitate low level merging of writing
work was actually used instead as a way
to clearly communicate high level ideas
so to sum up we saw that leaders play
this role of merging work too in order
to make it possible for contributions to
add to each other rather than having to
compete against each other as in
traditional crowdsourcing workflows so
here since we saw that ensemble worked
with smaller groups our next question
was to ask whether we could achieve a
similar collaboration with larger teams
so that thought sparked the creation of
the next project I'm going to talk about
mechanical novel so here rather than
using leaders to guide a collaborative
work around constraints we looked at how
we could get crowds to take on that
leader role for themselves while writing
short fiction stories so for in Samba
one major bottleneck was this leader who
had the coordinate contributions um
looking at everything coming in was a
huge burden on one person and leaders
told us that coming up with constraints
was sometimes difficult for them so the
question with mechanical novel was how
can we get crowds to monitor their own
and adjust their work accordingly so
like I mentioned earlier existing crowd
sourcing systems usually break down
complex tasks by splitting them into
independent parts that you can piece
together later or by using a workflow to
build on a task step-by-step however
this means that the system's can't
crowdsource work that has mutually
interdependent parts so for something
like a story changing the name of a
character for example requires you to
have to go through and change all
mentions of this character elsewhere
this gets even more complex if you start
changing more abstract things like a
character's motivation so already it's
pretty clear that what an expert creator
like an author does to make these types
of changes isn't what crowd sourcing
systems can currently do instead when
experts make these kinds of changes they
use reflection to engage in a sort of
conversation with their work so when
they reflect they continually evaluate
whether they like where they're going
and whether it's getting them closer to
their vision which itself might still be
forming in their head so rather than
using a static workflow to create
experts use reflection to determine if
they need to make changes and what their
next step should be so what would it
look like for a crowd to collaboratively
reflect on their work instead of
developing a static workflow to
accomplish the static hole we could
break down complex work by reflecting on
and revising high-level goals so to do
this the crowd can loop between two
phases first they reflect on the work so
far to brainstorm and choose a
high-level goal to pursue next and then
they revise the work by decomposing that
goal into small actionable tasks that
guide what edits workers should make so
to explore this technique we created a
system called mechanical novel for
writing purely crowdsource short fiction
stories hooked into Mechanical Turk the
starts by creating a first draft in
response to a story prom so this first
draft draft is usually not super great
but it allows the crowd to set an
initial rough direction for stories idea
so here we start off with a story prompt
the hot air balloon where a boy
accidentally flies to a city in the sky
and the crowd writes a short story one
paragraph at a time and uses votes to
pick the best text for each section next
the cloud the cloud the crowd starts to
reflect to do this we ask workers to
critique the story using a simple
feedback structure where the worker
rights something that they liked
something they wish was different and a
speculative what if that offers a
possible change the story could make
next oops we use these generated what
ifs as candidates for the crowds next
goal for the story so here workers have
offered a few different changes like
what if we could learn a little bit more
about Malcolm or what if we could expand
the ending so that Malcolm gets to
explore the cloud the cloud City the
crowd votes to select one of these
options as the main high-level goal for
work so let's say the crowd votes to
expand the story's ending so that
Malcolm can explore the Cloud City oops
ok the crowd then starts the revised
phase so after picking this high level
goal the crowd votes for which sections
of the story need to change in order to
achieve this goal along with specific
suggestions for what those changes
should be so here the crowd makes a few
votes indicating that maybe most workers
think that the last paragraph is the one
that needs to change in order to achieve
the goal of expanding the ending and
some options workers have written for
expanding the ending is to have Malcolm
exit the balloon and explore or maybe to
write in a villain that Malcolm has to
defeat before he can leave so workers
then vote among these suggestions so
let's say that workers think that
Malcolm should get out of the hot air
balloon to lick around this
I get the most votes become micro tasks
that ask workers to edit the text for a
particular section by acting as specific
instructions for how a section should
change so at this step work to see a
request to incorporate Malcolm getting
out of the hot air balloon into this
paragraph when it once edits are made
and workers vote for the best version of
edits this ends the revision phase of
work and that completes one round of
reflection and revision the process that
can then repeat allowing the crowd to
choose a new goal and revise a story
again this time tackling perhaps a
different problem so in this way the
crowd is able to determine a high level
goal for themselves which becomes a
measuring stick against which all
workers can see if their contributions
are doing the right thing and fitting in
with other people's work all without the
need for core leader that coordinates
everything so with this system our
hypothesis was that allowing the crowd
to revise their goals as they generate
creative work will result in better
creative outcomes that then approaches
that do not allow for reflection so to
look at this I ran two studies the first
was a benchmark evaluation to see
whether mechanical novel would be able
to detect and fix problems that we
artificially introduced into a short
story the second study was the sea of
mechanical novel would be able to write
a short story from scratch and to look
at the quality of the stories like I've
written both of these studies had two
experimental conditions the mechanical
novel condition which use the system
that I just described and the control
condition which represented a typical
crowdsourcing workflow where workers
jump straight into voting for how to
edit a story and making edits and skip
the part where they choose a high level
goal and workers who participated in
these studies were randomly assigned to
participate in one of these conditions
so first the benchmark study so with
this we wanted to get a sense of
mechanical novels strengths and
weaknesses and see if it was something
that we wanted to move forward with so
we started out with a short story
written by Sarah who's a master student
working on the mechanical novel project
and also a really good writer she chose
six common types of story problems
ranging from low-level things like
adding typos and grammar to high level
things like adding unnecessary
characters and using the original story
as a base she then wrote six new stories
each introducing one of these six
problems and so this gave us sort of a
gold standard to work from as we knew
exactly where and what the major
problems were for each story and how
we'd expect someone to fix them we then
ran mechanical novel and the control
system over each of these 12 stories for
just one revision round and then we
repeated all of that three times lastly
we lurked we looked at work as votes for
which paragraphs to edit as well as than
the actual edits that they made to
paragraph to determine how often crowd
workers were able to detect the problem
present in the story as well as how
often Cod workers were able to fix the
problem and so for this just to
highlight some of the more the most
interesting findings from this we found
that mechanical novel was more likely to
correctly identify the problematic story
sections for the abrupt ending problem
and extra characters problem while the
control condition was better at
detecting lower level issues like typos
both were equally good at detecting and
fixing sudden changes in the narrator's
point of view and these findings carried
over to each system strengths and fixing
certain problems as well as mechanical
novel workers seem to be better at
fixing the abrupt ending and even though
both systems were able to detect out of
character dialogue mechanical novel was
better at fixing this issue so already
we can sort of see a trend towards
mechanical novel being strong at
addressing these high level problems
with story with plot and with character
while the control system predictably
seemed to be better at addressing lower
level technical issues like spelling and
grammar so seeing how mechanical novel
my how am I differ from traditional
crowdsourcing workflows seem promising
so we wanted to see how mechanical novel
would perform in writing a story from
scratch so to do this we came up with
five story pumps ranging a variety of
topics and from these the cow generated
a first draft for each story containing
about six short scenes of texts
we then duplicated these first draft so
that the stories in the control
condition and in the mechanical novel
condition started from the same base
text we then ran each story through five
rounds of revisions again with
mechanical novel starting out with this
critique and what the control condition
skipping straight skipping the critique
and jumping straight into choosing which
sections of the story to edit so in
addition workers in both conditions who
participated in revising the story text
where optionally allowed to fill out a
short feedback form to indicate what
they thought was difficult or easy about
making edits and one stories were
written to evaluate stories for quality
we asked 215 Mechanical Turk workers who
had not worked on any of the story
writing tasks to compare the control and
Mechanical Turk versions for one of the
story prompts and we asked Turkish here
to choose which story they thought was
better in terms of several dimensions so
for example which story is better
imagery which story has better story
structure and so on and finally we did
an analysis of all story at its
critiques made how tasks were decomposed
as well as feedback that we received
from workers to look for themes in what
workers loss problems and how they
attempted to fix these problems so in
the end over 400 Mechanical Turk tests
later and 200 unique workers later we
ended up with 10 stories 5 revised by
the control condition and 5 revised by
mechanical novel stories took about 11
days to go through five rounds of
revision on average and again these were
short stories with stories being about
six hundred to a thousand words long and
overall we did find that our readers
liked stories written by mechanical
novel better to impact this we found
several interesting differences between
the mechanical novel and control stories
so first we found that mechanical novel
stories had significantly more developed
plots readers rated mechanical novel
stories is having more complete story
arcs with clearer beginning middles and
ends readers also rated mechanical novel
stories as having more original and
interesting central story ideas which is
interesting considering the fact that
both mechanical novel and control story
started from the same base first draft
and the blue elephant story that a crowd
workers wrote is a good example of how
mechanical novel was able to create a
better story arc so in the original
story a young girl realizes her stuffed
elephant is gone she looks all over for
it and in the end is reunited with it
and finds that it has come to life in
the control version workers attempted to
motivate the main character search by
briefly describing her relationship with
the elephant and also tried to add in a
reason for the elephants disappearance
so an improvement but could be better
the mechanical novel version in contrast
started with a description of how Kaylee
received the elephant from her
grandmother which was the same doll her
recently deceased mother had when she
was a little girl workers also tied this
idea into the ending which reveals that
Kaylee's love for her grandmother was
what brought the blue elephant to life
in the end creating the specific theme
that kind of threads through the whole
story and brings it together second we
found that mechanical novel seems to
focus workers efforts towards improving
the narrative so it seemed that workers
in the control condition actually spent
more of their effort fixing spelling and
grammar compared to mechanical novel
workers but in contrast mechanical novel
stories were rated as having better
imagery and description and writing
style so this and this focus on flushing
out the story itself was also
corroborated by the analysis we did of
types of edits that workers made to each
story where we found that workers in the
mechanical novel condition made
significantly more edits that expanded
on describing characters while workers
in the control condition trended towards
making more edits related to again
fixing grammar and spelling so for
example in this the control version of
the John Doe John Doe story which is a
story about a man who finds himself in
heaven started out like this a very
straightforward description of the main
character surrounding the mechanical
novel story however uses first-person
voice to narrate the main characters
findings thoughts and feelings as they
try to process an unfamiliar place
lastly we found that mechanical novel
allowed workers to coordinate their
creative efforts after analyzing the
feedback that workers wrote after
writing or revising story texts we found
that mechanical novel workers often
justified their work by saying that they
were following the suggestions
established by other workers meaning
that workers were they were working with
others to achieve this high-level goal
workers in the control condition on the
other hand were more trended towards
making edits that were more likely to
try and focus the stories direction
themselves and they were more likely to
try and justify their work by critiquing
the story as a whole so by this time
you're probably curious as to what one
of these stories actually looked like so
I'll walk through the control and
mechanical novel version of one of the
stories workers wrote during the study
so this particular story is about is I
guess like a film noir type story titled
number 16 and was about a serial killer
who's target suddenly disappears so this
initial first draft of the story as you
might expect was filled with
inconsistencies the very first paragraph
starts out with a major plot twist where
the to be victim actually catches the
main character of following her and
points a gun at him but the next
paragraph continues as if that hadn't
happened describing the serial killer as
waiting patiently to make his next move
and later on in the story the point of
view changes from the serial killer to
the victim suddenly drawing from the
plot twist idea earlier in the story
instead to narrating the victims
thoughts as she tries to hunt down the
serial killer instead but then the story
ends with a serial killer maybe killing
the victim it's not clear and that's how
it ends so in the control version of the
story workers were able to remove this
early plot twist and change the ending
so that the victim does turn the tables
on the serial killer but by fixing these
issues they ended up removing much of
the story arc including that kind of
important plot twist that activist
foreshadowing for that for that ending
resulting in kind of a monotone plot and
an ending that seems kind of random
in contrast the mechanical novel version
of the story like the control version
changes the ending so that the tables
are turned on the killer but also
removes well rather than removing the
plot twist the early plot twist
altogether transforms it into kind of a
foreshadowing for later parts of the
plot so instead of the victim catching
the serial killer following her she
actually kind of bumps into him and
asked him if like oh like are you okay
or you need anything he's like oh no I'm
fine and she acts oblivious whereas
later on you find out that she actually
knew everything that was happening so
that was really interesting in addition
mechanical novels workers also added
back stories for the serial killer and
the victim to explain why they're doing
what they're doing in the story just
another example of how mechanical novels
seem to focus more on expanding
characters so in summary we found that
workers in the mechanical novel
condition focused on higher level story
problems than workers in the control
condition and we're less likely to try
and hijack the direction of the story
when contributing work workers were able
to select a reasonable high level goals
for themselves and use these goals to
break down the task of revising a short
story into coordinated actions so the
last project I'm going to talk about is
mosaic so where ensemble and mechanical
novel specifically looked at translating
a certain expert creative practice for
use in crowd work with mosaic I wanted
to look at expert mindsets failure
struggle unexpected setbacks and new
inspirations are all part of creative
work so how can we encourage this in the
design of social systems for creators so
to set the stage for where this idea is
coming from online creative communities
today like deviantart pixiv and dribble
focus on showcasing completed work
creating a climate where creators aim to
produce work that isn't impressive as
possible to attract viewers and fans and
this is a great opportunity to get
feedback from others and to look at
examples of other people's really cool
work and creators do try to capitalize
this in a lot of ways sometimes they
carve out social spaces for sharing in
progress work that will create and
curate tutorials
it or organized event specifically for
tackling creative challenges and this
makes sense because we already know from
past literature and creativity that
improving skills centers around
continually assessing one one's creative
process based on feedback and
exploratory experiments so obviously
many creators already know this which is
why they try to foster these activities
based around creative process but
despite these efforts to help each other
in development and growth creators find
themselves having to compete against
impressive finished work when uploading
earlier and finished work to explain
their process processes to each other
which may discourage people from
participating in these activities but
what if creative communities were
designed from the get-go to allow
creators to share a creative process as
first-class content rather than just
sharing finished work creators could
share in progress snapshots of work to
illustrate what they did and why so by
designing a social environment that
rewards sharing early work we may create
better opportunities for creators to not
only learn specific techniques from each
other but also enable them to reflect
more effectively on their own work and
on others work so to get a sense of how
community like this might compare
against existing our communities I first
interviewed ten artists about there are
communities that they already use to
show their work an overall interviewee
said that they do mainly use existing
sites like deviantart facebook and
tumblr to share their artwork for the
purpose of getting as much exposure as
they can and while they have and while
many of them have post works in progress
on these sites in the past these were
mainly to serve mostly a social purpose
kind of like a hey here's what i'm up to
here's kind of a sneak peek at what i
would i do kind of thing and the reason
is because uh there are many technical
or social barriers that they have to
face when trying to share their process
such as having to go through a tedious
process of concatenated a bunch of
pictures into a single image or being
seen as spammy for posting too many
pictures of the same artwork at
different stages preventing them from
posting substantial content more often
so with the barriers that these artists
mentioned in mind I designed and
launched mosaic an online social art
platform where the primary method of
sharing artwork is to upload multiple
images illustrating the creative process
the steps that an artist takes to create
a piece of artwork so for example just
to kind of walk through how it works say
we have a mosaic user name cookie cat
who just started a still life oil
painting of their favorite dessert so
they might create a work in progress
representing their first step which is
drawing a sketch and this work in
progress on mosaic would include a
description of any reasoning behind
their steps such as why they chose a
certain type of subject matter or how
they chose a certain visual composition
related works in progress are grouped
together in a project which represents a
single creative work so cookie cat might
create a project representing their
still-life cookie painting adding works
in progress representing stages of
development of their artwork from sketch
to under painting maybe to blocking and
colors and so on other social features
on mosaic an able artist to view what
others are doing so the home page
consists of a feed of recent activity
and shows comments new projects and new
updates to existing projects you can
also search for projects by keyword or
even by specific type of work in
progress and all this put together
allows creators to focus on sharing
knowledge with each other so say we have
another user named donut dog who happens
to see that cookie cat has recently
added an update to a painting very
similar to the kind of painting that
donut dog wants to make and so they
click to take a look and don't know dog
is surprised by cookie cats use of an
underpainting to kind of blackout
shadows and light early in the process
which is a technique that they're not as
familiar with so donut dog favorites
this project to subscribe to this
project updates in the future and leaves
a comment thanking cookie cat for
teaching something new so in this way by
centering users interactions around
sharing process mosaic is able to unlock
a number of
people interactions between creators
such as including being able to compare
your own creative process with others
learn new techniques and provide
feedback in a specific timely way so my
hypothesis with mosaic was that sharing
creative processes is difficult for
creators because existing creative
communities are designed to reward
sharing high-quality creative outcomes
so instead an alternative design for a
community designed around sharing works
in progress may encourage creators to
share early work and learn from each
other so in order to understand the
difficulties artists faced when seeking
or sharing works in progress online we
conducted a field deployment of mosaic
over the course of four weeks and
invited users from artists from
hobbyists art communities to use mosaic
to host snapshots of works in progress
we're snapshots of work in progress is
of whatever they happen to be working on
and during the study period we logged
all community activity including the
creation of projects work-in-progress
snapshots project favorites user follows
and so on and finally at the end of the
study period we conducted
semi-structured interviews with 10 of
the most active mosaic users as measured
by their commenting and project posting
activity to understand whether posting
works in progress affected their
creative practice and how they
interacted with other mosaic users so by
the end of the study period a total of
forty-six users created 69 projects with
projects containing an average of about
five works in progress each and each
receiving an average of about two
comments and there's an interesting
range in the types of images that people
would upload so while many people
uploaded a typical step-by-step set of
images like in this example others would
post work of their post photos of their
work environment and tools or include
maybe initial exploratory sketches that
weren't ultimately used and speaking
with interview interview participants we
did find that mosaic seemed to provide a
significantly different experience from
existing art communities that they
frequent so first participants described
posting about their process as a useful
way for them to
left on their own work so a few artists
including this participant pointed out
that documenting their process on mosaic
would be useful to their future selves
to help them remember that this
beautiful painting that they're so proud
of actually did start out kind of
horrible so they don't feel bad about a
horrible start to a new project secondly
works in progress on mosaic seem to
allow other creators to pinpoint the
intent of the Creator posting artwork
leading to inform feedback from the
community as a whole participants found
this useful as this meant that they
could use other users comments as a
mirror to kind of help them reflect on
whether or not they were able to achieve
their goals posting works in progress
also implicitly enforced a kind of a
community of reciprocity so many artists
like this participant mentioned that a
principle of fairness or a desire to
give back to the community drove their
motivation to create tutorials or write
feedback for others but enforcing this
fairness can be quite difficult on
existing sites like diviner in contrast
many participants described both posting
works in progress and posting comments
for others as kind of teaching
opportunities on mosaic so in other
words creators ended up framing the
their mosaic projects that they uploaded
it as kind of gifts of knowledge to
others and this was the same mechanism
through which people received feedback
and help and lastly we found that mosaic
allowed artists to feel less
apprehensive about sharing their work so
on existing sites the goal is to compete
with others for views and comments but
in contrast mosaic centred user activity
around making updates on progress of
artwork creating an environment where
sharing process was something that
everybody was doing and making people
focus less on the final outcome and more
on sharing a journey so in summary
mosaic demonstrates some of the benefits
of designing creativity support tools
and communities around outcomes other
than traditional success such as
experimentation exploration or even
failure these are all clearly important
parts of the creative process and
creating such tools
would help expand the ways in which
social systems and other technology can
help support creators so in this talk I
presented three projects ensemble
mechanical novel and mosaic through
these project I explored how adapting
existing existing creative practices by
experts can help us design new kinds of
crowdsourcing workflows and social
computing systems for accomplishing
collaborative open-ended creative tasks
these projects also touch on specific
design patterns that came out of
embedding expert practices into social
systems for example easing constraints
to help collaborative collaborator
strike a balance between free creativity
and working in sync with others letting
reflection dr collaborative action to
allow crowds to work together flexibly
and aiming to create a me for creating a
social environment that embraces process
rather than trying to act as a gallery
but more broadly my works a major
contribution to the field of HCI is
creating crowdsourcing and social
competing systems that focus on
supporting a creative process so through
ensemble mechanical novel I developed a
technique for extracting strategies from
expert practice and embedding them into
the design of collaborative tools for
accomplishing complex creative work with
crowds in all of my projects I
contributed working proof of concept
social systems and crowdsourcing
workflows to show that an expert
practice can be incorporated with the
design of a system to improve the
quality of creative outcomes and through
mosaic I expanded the possible space of
creativity support tools to include
tools that value process and not just
final outcome specifically proposing
design affordances like sharing the
process behind artwork instead of just
the staring this process behind artwork
and show how this affects interactions
between creators in an online community
and these contributions open up a number
of interesting avenues for future work
first we could explore other designs for
crowdsourcing systems that allow crowd
workers to direct their own work so for
example orienting work around high-level
goals like we did a mechanical novel may
be great in early stages of writing a
story when ideas are still developing
but late in later stages when you might
want to actually focus on cleaning up
spelling and grammar and fixing the
sentences that'll flow well a more
traditional crowdsourcing system may
actually be actually be more helpful so
it would be interesting to see if a
crowdsourcing system could dynamically
adjust the degree to which it focused on
high level or low level work and see how
that affects the creative output of the
crowd secondly a major area of research
has drawn on the fact that the crowd is
physically spread in many different
locations so rather than maybe relying
on ad-hoc behavior or some sort of
central governing figure we might be
able to use the strategies that we saw a
mechanical novel to self-organize for
example maybe citizen reporting efforts
or humanitarian efforts in cases of like
a natural disaster when central
direction isn't readily available and
lastly we could expand the design
direction we explored with mosaic and
perhaps generate a new design space of
creativity support tools and communities
designed around sharing process so
mosaic was just kind of the tip of the
iceberg there you could add on to this
direction by thinking about a community
that allows creators to maybe create
techniques into personal tool boxes or
libraries or imagined communities where
people explicitly showcase failures
instead of focusing on success thinking
beyond just traditional success opens
opportunities for new ways like creators
could help support each other okay so
just before I wrap things up I want to
thank you all for listening um I also
want to thank a lot of other people as
well first and foremost my advisor
Michael Bernstein who's been a great
source of support for me not only in
times where I wanted to give up on
projects that didn't seem like they're
going anywhere but also making sure that
I remembered to celebrate my victories
as well and never letting me forget that
yeah
to do some pretty cool stuff during my
PhD I also want to thank my committee
manish mira Pam and James for taking
their time out of their busy schedules
to be here you know some of you have
known longer than others but all of you
have been very kind and encouraging and
wonderful mentors to me I've also had
the opportunity to work with some of the
most smart and dedicated hard-working
people I know during my time here I also
want to thank all my friends I in the
office and everyone else that I've met
here while at Stanford especially the
best office mates in the world Neela far
Lydia away and deny thanks also to our
admins Julia and Monica for keeping me
and everyone else fed through our weekly
lunches and also not getting mad at me
for emailing them a billion Mechanical
Turk receipts and lastly much love to my
parents and to my sisters who didn't
really know what I was doing here but
believed I was doing a good job at it
whatever it was
uh yeah and that's it for my talk I'm
happy to take questions now or if you
prefer you can contact me by email
thanks war is open yeah hi that's great
i have a very general question time I'm
not feminine cross also how who it is
what are the demographics like of these
topics like video jobs at how educated
at a wedding from and how is the crowd
sourcing like let's keep growing it is a
mechanical tougher example going on the
web user so i scroll saying like dying
out of them hmm those are deep question
um as for the demographics there has
been i should be familiar with this
there has been research on like
explicitly figuring out who these people
are for uh for my projects i focus
specifically on crowd workers from the
united states though i think there's a
pretty huge range of like these aren't
just like there's a pretty huge range of
people on Mechanical Turk a lot of them
have other jobs a lot of them are
stay-at-home people who would do stuff
in spare time some people do it for fun
some people do it to like make a little
extra income so if there's a really big
range of motivations and type of people
who are on there I think for the most
part people tend to a view Mechanical
Turk is like in general the kind of
assumption is that Mechanical Turk
workers tend to be not trained in very
specific things and so they're kind of
like a general non-expert I guess we
would say to use like there because in
contrast those other research that looks
at crowdsourcing and using populations
of expert workers so recruiting people
from up work or these are the kinds of
things where you can there are a lot of
workers on their very specialized in
certain kinds of
so yeah yeah great work awesome awesome
sci-fi-ness bezar so I'm interested to
hear your thoughts about sort of in
terms of the mosaic project so you know
there's a you know often on youtube
you'll find people have like time-lapse
videos of them doing work or other
things like that how do you think
something like that sort of time-lapse
approach versus very structured or in
some case having more contextual
information that they can provide in
terms of the single images changes the
way that you are able to use that
obviously it seems like you know you can
look glance at it more quickly but what
are the other things and do you think
about other year or other ways that you
could present some of these types of
sort of in progress work yeah that's a
really good question um yeah so uh among
the IRS that I talking to sort of video
recordings of our very popular and they
have a lot of benefits being able to see
somebody like create something stroke by
stroke is also very informative the one
thing is that we wanted to kind of get
at so these things are uploaded all at
once like there's no opportunity for
someone to kind of jump in and be like
okay like at minute 30 like you lose
hand along or something I thought I'd is
no opportunity for that kind of two-way
interaction there it's a very one-way
thing where an artist draws something
they record it they upload it and that's
it like it's sort of pushed out into the
world and be like okay learn for me
that's cool um so it's useful but we
wanted to get a kind of this what would
the sort of two-way interaction look
like if you could post work as you were
working on it and get input from a
community right away yeah and so uh but
we do thinking about how that sort of
thing could fit into mosaic some of the
artists that we've talked to thought it
would be really cool to be able to like
instead of just post images like maybe
post video clips for each step or
something like that or being able to
link to a live stream that they were
working on so if they uploaded a project
on mosaic and then they happen to be
currently working on it and live
streaming they become one of them so
they would be cool to be able to like
flip that flag and be like oh hey I'm
working on this project
right now come here mosaic users like
i'm looking at i'm doing this right now
and so so they had a lot of ideas for
how we could kind of plug in this this
sort of thing into their kind of
existing practices and there seems to be
a lot of opportunity there yeah the idea
well I'm like what the effects of the
additional structure is on like
motivation enjoyment and learning
compared to like that just like less
structured writing motivation enjoyment
and learning hmm um could you say more
about what you're interested in asking
like a sound like qualitative feedback
or anything of that sort that you may
have received from like the people just
like the big lady working on it just
like the be yeah um we did get a lot of
comments that people found it very fun
like like we got it we got a bunch of
comments like oh yeah it was great
better than a bunch of mindless click
thing and like we had to actually like
think about stuff so I think they
enjoyed that kind of thing to the point
where and then again this sort of ties
into different people's motivation for
being on Mechanical Turk like some
people spent way more time than they
were probably supposed to UM on it
because they enjoyed it so much and
people like people would say things like
oh I spent like 20 minutes on this but I
don't care it was like really cool other
people would be like oh I spent 20
minutes on this pay me for it and be
like oh sorry um so it's a little bit
hard to kind of gauge what people got
out of it um then general it didn't seem
that people found it unique and
interesting um and I think the fact that
we were able just kind of for the most
part fit these little creative tasks
into a micro task kind of package I
think was very well received oh gosh Oh
Sharon mean actually believes did mosaic
a nice lunging
some of the feedback method people used
in ensembl explosive when you're not
humble about people provide like
alternative paragraphs and we think my
thing is there's a yeah it is yeah
so that is our practice called redlining
so people do do this sometimes on like
some of the bigger like work-in-progress
critique forums that already exist the
thing is I think that's definitely
something that we could build into
mosaic because i think that would tie
into like design a community directly
designed for that kind of thing because
currently to do this kind of redlining
stuff you have to download what the
people uploaded you have to like draw it
yourself and photoshop and like upload
it back somewhere and hope that they see
it or you post on the right thread or
whatever so yeah it would be interesting
to kind of integrate that thing in into
mosaic because it's definitely something
that people like to see and want to do
again also probably because it's easier
to kind of explain through doing it
instead of trying to like translate into
words um yeah I think that's definitely
something people would want any function
war period help you recruit artists for
mosaic given the UK's picked random the
campus workers yeah I'm so I didn't to a
few our communities on there so I kind
of just advertising these are
communities that I'm already plugged
into and recruited people from there um
so it was a little bit easier
considering that I like I was sort of I
wasn't just like a random person like I
was sort of like in that group already
and so people were but open to trying
this new thing out
thank you oh so I was just thinking
because of the structure and mechanical
arm you think it's good platform to
develop like dynamic storyline like kind
of a throwback to choose your own
adventure books that I used to read as a
kid so now that you have people willing
this out sort of right off parts of the
story so let's say you this Junction
started I can have people on this bus
other group of people within this button
so if you would publish a story you kind
of have interesting model because you
don't no longer have it published in a
physical form and some people could sort
of we stock a different legal detect so
don't know what your thoughts in it yeah
so we don't even think about doing that
at first even way back with ensemble and
there are there are other research
projects out there that have kind of
explored this like hypermedia approach
of like people branching out and you
know seeing whether how it affects how
people collaborate or how people feel
about the contributions to like a
branding story versus like just a one
with no branching for us we decided not
to pursue that route just because I
think that issue for that well I found
interesting was that um how do people
resolve differences in opinion about
what the central story line should be so
I think branching would I think would be
interesting to explore but not answer
that question so that's kind of why we
went with that research direction so
efficient I mean like a few projects I
was wondering for mechanical novel if
you notice any significant impact of the
number of people
project to the quality of the outcome
what I mean is was it linear in ink in
that as you increase the number of
people that are working on the novel the
quality the outcome got better was it
that was it more of a curve was it that
there's a sweet spot and after which it
just got two more like too many chefs
did you think about that or what do you
feel about that rabbits hmm that would
be interesting to look at so we didn't
we didn't that was not something that we
manipulated in mechanical novel but I
think it would be interesting to look at
it like an interesting direction for
future word form broadly I think would
be looking at how to kind of model these
sorts of things like you know what
effect does like the number of crowd
workers have on the quality of creative
output or like you think about turning
other kinds of knobs and levers to
figure that out um uh for my just my gut
sense you know yeah I'm not really sure
I think we'd have to like do it and like
see it is kind of interesting because we
did get on some workers especially in
the blue elephant story where it was
about a girl who lost her stuffed animal
a lot of people wrote about their
personal experiences like as a kid which
I thought was kind of interesting so be
interesting to see how much that
affected the story or not yeah good
question